[Music]
hi folks i'm having a conversation with
jonathan pejo he's an artist and a
public speaker who
i suppose rose to prominence uh through
his work with jordan peaceon uh jonathan
how are you
i've been great it's good to meet you
i've i've been following your work i
guess
since jordan peterson kind of appeared
online and he was on your channel i
started to pay attention a little bit to
you and so it's uh it's nice to talk to
you
yeah thank you um right so um i guess
the
the best place for us to start would
probably be i don't know about 10 or 20
years ago with the sort of rise of the
new atheists i think uh
this this is the sort of foundation of
the the root of one of the problems that
we found ourselves in
um would you like to tell me what your
opinion of the new atheists is and
how you feel that their movement has
developed and what's happened to it
i would say on the one hand i when the
new atheists kind of appeared on
the scene i was very aggravated with
their
with their the way they spoke and their
arguments
but i also felt like people couldn't
understand the counter argument it's
very strange
people were struggling to understand how
what how to frame the counter argument
um and i've been kind of developing my
ideas for years
not just about that but partly about how
to answer this kind of argument
and then jordan peterson appeared and we
realized when he discovered my work as
well that we were on the same page and i
feel like he broke through the wall
in trying to explain the problem of the
new atheist
movement and bringing back the notion of
consciousness the problem of framing and
of
uh the question of uh how phenomena
manifest itself and patterns all of this
stuff which
the new atheists just ignored because
they were so focused on kind of science
scientific questions
they didn't realize the the problem of
the viewer and the problem of
consciousness in the
whole let's say in the pattern of all of
this together
so i feel like that has been kind of
broken and also we're seeing more and
more as we watched
our society break down we watch how
everything is fragmenting and
people are at each other's throats that
the the glue that unites us together
it's slipping and you know and we it's
not based on facts it's
something more it's something like
identity or something you know something
that brings us together and the question
is
what is the foundation of that unity and
i think that that's also a place where a
lot of
people who are interested in the new
atheist argument are
wondering okay so okay so if we agree
with this kind of argumentation
then why do we exist as societies like
what binds us together
yeah i i've got a very um similar view
because i mean i don't know whether you
know about my personal history but i
mean i was always a
huge fan of christopher hitchens uh
being somewhat of a contrarian myself
and it's only as i have matured
out of my 20s and 30s now into my 40s
that i realize how short-sighted the new
atheist seems to have been
because i mean it's very easy to
break apart the dogmatism that comes
from a 2000 year old book
obviously it's not going to be
consistent or scientific or rational
obviously it vastly predates that era
but that's kind of missing the point of
it isn't it
because the the really the point i think
is to provide sort of um
moral direction and i think that uh
without this when you take this away you
kind of leave people
in a bit of a fog not knowing what they
should be doing with their lives
and we're kind of left in this very sort
of hedonistic utilitarian period
where almost anything seems to go now
there's no particular boundaries anymore
other than
direct physical harm and so if you're
not directly harming someone or it's not
obvious that you've someone's
in pain then pretty much anything goes
doesn't it
yeah and my argument i would say
starts a little bit before that in the
sense that
i think that religion is that is not
really about
morality at first glance it's morality
it's about morality downstream
but at the first level it's about
creating a
a pattern of being a pattern of how the
world exists
and so and and so it's very imagistic it
ends up being an imagistic pattern
a story pattern uh also a architectural
pattern you can imagine
like a pattern in space how space
manifests itself
um and then from there there will be
some moral questions which will come
down but
once you look at the sacred text in
terms of uh
a story in terms of imagistic really
much almost like if you're reading lord
of the rings and you want to understand
lord of the rings
if you read the bible that way you'll
understand it a lot better than if you
try to nitpick at it and try to find
how it's scientifically not accurate but
if you look at it as a kind of
grand story and a grand narrative in
which we are
we frame our existence then then not
only is it actually quite coherent
but you realize that the categories that
are used in
scripture let's say are actually the
categories that
although not scientific are the
categories that we live in
right and you could say something like
you know the sun
the sun doesn't turn around the earth
and and then you could you could
make all these arguments to say how
stupid people who thought that in the
past were but you still get up in the
morning and you still go to bed at night
and the sun still goes down over the
horizon
and so phenomenologically it's still an
experience that manages our life yeah
the way the way i've been uh viewing
this
is essentially separating the two
thought processes out into
scientific thinking and what i guess
i'll just call mythological thinking
and both have predictive power and this
is something that i think that people
who are
entirely bound up with scientific
thinking can't bring themselves to admit
uh it doesn't matter if helios isn't
really pushing the chariot of the sun
around the earth every day
uh the point is you know an ancient
greek uh pagan knows that the sun's
gonna rise in the morning the next day
and he knows he's gonna get a procession
of uh seasons so he knows when to plant
it's gone
and so even though you know it might not
technically be correct it still has
predictive power and
it's it's woven into a larger scheme of
meaning for that
person and allows them to kind of
identify their place in the world
relative to others
and things like this and this is what i
think that the
the the ball i think the new atheists
dropped with
the deconstruction of christianity and
other religions of course
um is that it's most people's daily life
is actually a lot more mythological than
it is scientific
you know most people don't really
understand why a lot of the things that
happen around them happen
uh it's you know on a technical level
but they do have the kind of
superstitious sort of view of the world
and this this i just think is just
normal
this is most people's lives and this is
how people i think think of themselves
as well you know you are your own story
in which you are a hero you know you are
the protagonist and you know there are
villains the people who bullied you at
school or you know
whatever it is you know there are the
villains of this story and so i don't
think it's illegitimate to think of
ourselves
in a less scientific way and in fact
i've been thinking about this a lot like
it seems actually
to encompass the kind of spark of
the the the precious nature of a human
life
can actually be very easily dismissed as
soon as you abandon the kind of
uh religious worldview or the
mythological worldview
uh it seems very easy to justify
killing a lot of people which happened
all through the 20th century yeah and
not only that but if you look at people
today and
and who may let's say who think that
religion is superfluous and think that
let's say just secular culture is fine
they're still
on the horizon anti-natalist and
anti-human sentiment even in the
the ecological movement there's massive
anti-human
uh sentiment in that and people don't
realize how far that can go and what
that can lead to
but they they take up the arguments in
everyday life you'll meet someone who
who will say how how we're parasites on
the earth and how you know we're
destroying everything and it's like man
that's that's there's some scary stuff
down the line from that type of
argumentation that you don't understand
oh totally i mean i i remember seeing an
argument that we shouldn't
mine asteroids and that we should leave
them for the universe and it's like
why what what you know
and and again like even even though even
though they end up in this kind of uh
you know like you say anti-human
sort of view i mean there's something
kind of mythological about the way
they're conceiving of the universe
there's a kind of holistic divine whole
that mankind
is sullying or profaning in some way by
mining these asteroids or whatever it is
and i i just find this to be a
ridiculous sentiment
yeah well i think that one of my
arguments has really been
that if you don't take care of the
mythological
in an explicit manner if you don't have
uh rituals if you don't have sacred
spaces if you don't have
the structures that let's say manifest
this aspect of the human person
then it's going to be there anyways it's
you can't get rid of it and it's good
it's going to come back in
all kinds of insane crazy ways like we
saw in the us with all the george floyd
protests they were religious in nature
everything they were doing
this the self-flagellation the kneeling
the iconography
all of it yeah you had these images of
him as like a saint or even as christ
sometimes
and so the idea is if you
try to say that this is irrelevant it's
going to creep back and it's going to
show
itself in in monstrous manner so it's
better to to deal with it explicitly and
to have
you know to have rituals to have sacred
spaces to have this
as part of what a culture is rather than
leave it up to the chaos to kind of
manifest these these passions let's say
oh i i totally agree with you and like
it does seem to be just an innate
characteristic of
like humans being able to kind of
heuristically guide themselves through
the world
you know and have a general
understanding of things it seems like
it's inevitable
and innate and inescapable and i think
this is kind of the um the great conceit
of the enlightenment is that we can
become these scientific rational beings
it's like well
maybe we can but for about a hundred
thousand years we weren't
and i think it's a bit arrogant to uh
suggest that something would just flip
the table and suddenly everything will
be different
everyone will be perfectly rational and
the thing is as soon as you enter into
that mind space you realize that you're
being
entirely materialistic and one one of
the things that um
i really kind of despise actually i'm
beginning to really despise about
enlightenment thought generally
is the interchangeability of everything
this is a really real concern for me i
mean it's fine when you're talking about
material products
but even then it make you know the
commodification of everything
even human beings means you have to
reduce everything to its most basic
parts
and so there's nothing special or unique
or artistic anymore
but but then essentially you as an
individual have no special value
you know you're not mythic um and the
the the uh
the uh i've had a lot of people asking
me recently like um
for some because i've been talking about
the subject and the way that i've been
trying to explain it is that look like
if i
found the sword of alexander the great
you know you might be able to you know
if i and i could guarantee i
i broke into his tomb or something you
know and in his coffin i pull out his
sword
that sword has got like mythical
significance to the people who know who
alexander the great is and think of him
in in good manner you know you you can
make all the replicas of this you want
you could
set up a factory line producing replicas
of alexander the great sword
but they will never be alexander the
great sword you know i'll have the only
one
and it's it's the same thing with you
know every and this is the kind of
it's like an overlay that goes over the
world you know the sort of mythical
narrative
you know it's like the the spear of
longinus you know the piece of the true
cross all of these things are totally
irreplaceable and they are beyond the
concept of value you know they are
priceless so they're inevitable
and it's actually the world manifests
itself even
our own categories even all the
categories we use even the scientific
categories we use
to define the world are value-laden
because the
all f let's say all phenomena has an
indefinite amount of ways you could
describe it
it has an indefinite amount of
possibilities of of existing let's say
and so the categories we use are always
categories which take into account
the importance that humans have for it
even like i said in scientific research
like we
we the even in research the funding that
goes into research will be based on
values
that will decide what is important to
research and what is important to
understand
so even though it's objective in terms
of the facts that they find
the reason why we're even looking at
those facts is is based on value
and that's been i would say one of the
main things that i've been trying to do
for the past four years is to help
people understand hierarchy
is to help people understand how
hierarchy lays itself out
how these all the images we have from
scripture the
the temple the tabernacle the mountain
heaven and earth
you know the garden with the central
tree all of these images are there to
help us understand
what hierarchy is but and once you
understand that you also can understand
what's happening to us now
because understanding hierarchy also
means understanding how that breaks down
and the image of how hierarchy breaks
down is a way to understand what is
happening to us
right and so this idea from the ancient
world that you had your own fellows
right you had your navel of the world
and on the edge of the world you had all
these monsters with like strange
heads and and mixtures of different
animals it's like you can think that
that's mythical but when you see the
crazy tattooed pierced
person with pink hair you're like it's
not it's happening to you right now
these monsters are coming out of the
dark and they're coming out into the
street so don't tell me it's just a
it's just a story because it's happening
to us no no i totally agree again
it has predictive value if you go far
enough away from the familiar
you're going to come into a realm of
essentially monsters you know it's going
to be exactly as you say it's going to
be strange it's going to be dangerous
you're not going to know what's
happening and it's going to be an
adventure that in the you know
the hero's journey of it you get back
and you're going to explain to everyone
look i saw some crazy stuff out there
and this happens everywhere you know
this this happens when i went over to la
for the first time you know i had to
explain to my like my wife and my family
you know
people over there are very different you
know it's it's a strange world you know
uh compared to compared to my nice house
in england um
so this is true about everything not
just like let's say human interaction
stories but
even normal categories of being like
like i always use example of a cup
so there's an identity of a cup like
there's an invisible pattern of the of a
cup
and then there are examples of cups in
the world and there are some examples
that are like
is it a cup is it a glass it's it it's
in between it's kind of it's kind of
on the fringe of what a cup can be and
that's totally fine
as long as you can see that it's kind of
a monster cup then it has its
role in the world it's fine for it to be
there like it's also fine for the
monsters to exist they
they're they're inevitable in how the
world lays itself out the problem is
when the monster tries to take the
the throne right the monster the problem
is when the monster tries to get into
the altar
that's the problem it's not that there
are monsters out there and they're that
there are things that
don't fit into categories those are
normally there and that you can't get
rid of them
the problem we have now is that it's
like we're in the monsters have come
into the
they're coming in and they're trying to
take the throne and that's
it's not good for the monsters either
which is something that a lot of the
monsters don't understand
because you are you you're not gonna
like it there
it's because your whole idea is to not
be normative if you're not normative
why would you want to take the normality
yeah
and not be good to you i find that
really interesting actually it's a
really
good way of framing it because and you
are
you're essentially setting the entire
hierarchy on its head
and put it putting the thing that should
be the furthest from being in charge
in charge and so that's going to change
the nature of everything
uh any any justifying or legitimating
structures that you had
are going to suddenly have to change
they're going to become illegitimate
things are going to be completely
different
and and not only that but you take away
the meaning of the people who are
already invested in this hierarchy and
we i don't know whenever you say the
word hierarchy it sounds
it sounds like there's implicitly a form
of oppression
tied up in it but that's but that's not
the case and
i mean some hierarchies of course are
oppressive naturally
but uh others are not oppressive and in
fact are conducive to liberty
conducive to freedom and security and
happiness and prosperity you know
if without a state we don't have
property rights and therefore we need
this kind of hierarchy in order to make
sure that
the contract for this office is enforced
you know so the the landlord doesn't
just turf me out and take my money you
know there's
there's all sorts of reasons that we
have these things and you're right
putting putting the
the unknown monsters in charge of the
hierarchy
is bad for everyone it's a great one the
hierarchy
hierarchy is both it's both at the same
time it's it's a method of
exclusion and a method of participation
it also
shows you how to participate in the
pattern because without a hierarchy
you have no way of knowing right you
have no way of knowing who's the best
runner if you don't have a
hierarchy of runners and so once you
have a higher care runner it's like okay
here here's the best runner i'm not that
good and now i know
what access i have like where am i on
the on the the ladder
and i can have to reach i can reach up i
can try to
to get better in my hierarchy but
without the hierarchy if you just
let's say let's say you start you have a
race and then for slower people you get
them you let them start first because
you know they're slower then all of a
sudden everything just breaks down
because
you don't even know like what excellence
is and you don't even
you're even if you win there's no value
in the winning they
it's just become a blind point to do
that would be to
avoid the concept of a winner or a loser
wouldn't it if you're trying to
sort of equalize these things you're
saying there's actually something wrong
with being a winner and a loser
and you i like the way you um the frame
as well the uh the sort of inclusive
nature of it
if there is no hierarchy what are you
trying to be included in
and that's why one of the like i've been
talking about this recently
i've been pushing it and i i made a
video recently on parasitic storytelling
you know with like all the crazy stuff
we're seeing in the franchises
and my point at the in the end was that
because the the the weird kind of
parasitic storytelling of like you know
the the women beating up the men
and all the stuff that we're seeing in
in these stories uh it always has to
re-establish the hierarchy
because it has to be the victim of it
and so in the end
in the very pattern of this weird upside
down world is
the key to bringing it right side up
because this the position of the center
is always open
because they have to restate it all the
time and so what ends up
the key now to storytelling i think and
i'm telling people this is
keep an eye out for these types of
stories are kind of return of the king
stories
right where the world becomes upside
down robin hood style you know an
illegitimate
kind of horrible prince takes over and
then
the good guy has to act like a robber
and has to be like a trickster
and then it flips back when or the lion
heart comes back and then
we reestablish a normal a normal order
and i think that that's also it's also
one of the reasons why people like you
for example and
other people who were there you know
several years ago appeared at first as
kind of weird
trickster kind of uh let's say uh troll
type figures
and then slowly shifted towards people
who kind of saw the pattern and
saw the the importance of of social
hierarchies and stories and all of this
and so it's like these weird
upside down figures who were kind of end
it now are ending up bringing back
a kind of order you know this is the
robin hood figure i would say
i i totally agree and i like the use of
the um the robin hood metaphor that
you're using here because the
the the the entire sort of arc of robin
hood
really does come back around to the king
reintegrating robin
in to his court uh so i i think the
earliest stories he wasn't actually a
noble but like in later tellings he was
but the
the point is robin hood represents um an
aspect of
the the the culture uh
that is responding to something that is
fundamentally wrong
something that is unjust something is
not being dealt with as
is proper and as you say the return of
the king the legitimate king
the legitimate king recognizes what
robin hood is doing and why he's doing
it
you know and that that's an important
thing and you're right i mean i think
that people
like myself the sort of you know
dissident outlaw types
um i i i agree i think that's the reason
we're doing anything we're doing to be
honest
there's something right and it's very
fast i talked about this
like in 2017 i was talking about you and
milo and uh
all these weird figures that kind of
appeared online and and talking about
how when
when the world is upside down then the
fool is going to turn it right side up
and so one of the hashtags i put out is
called watch the fools and like kanye
west is playing that role right now
kanye is totally playing that role
where he is a crazy guy like he's still
wild and crazy and does weird stuff but
then he says things that no one is
allowed to say
because he's seen as this kind of full
character and he says things that no
one's allowed to say
and it's actually just normal common
sense
like the most common sense thing he ends
up saying but no one else is because
it's like because the world is upside
down normal things aren't uh
we can't even say normal things no i
totally agree and one one of the um
one of the things i found interesting is
that kanye did an interview with the tmz
uh new uh sort of celebrity news out
there and
in the studio he was getting a lot of
grief from
other black people who worked at the
thing but he didn't
approach this you could see it in his
face he did he wasn't offended
uh he just had a very determined look on
his face
as in right i know i'm right i know i
can see something true
how can i project this across and the
problem was getting his message across
not the fact that he wasn't sure about
his message
and i was like i've been following
kanye's sort of political activism in
the same way
because i i really think that what he
did was very brave
uh when in 2018 he's wearing the maga
hat and went to the white house i think
that's tremendously brave
and he's doing it out of almost like a
there's a weird
kind i think there's an impulse in these
kinds of characters that kind of tricks
their characters
and it's a and it's really a pattern of
being where you know you have these
these
these kind of holy fool characters or
these traditional characters in ancient
societies like the jester
or the heyoka in native american
cultures where
their whole role is to point out you
know the foibles of the system
right and so they're there to point out
how the system is limited
but the question is when the whole
system is corrupt and what does the fool
have to do
if they're going to point out something
they're going to actually point out the
need for the system it's going to be
it's just
it's like an impulse it's just it's just
going to happen yeah no i totally agree
like
i i think that the the fool uh plays the
role of
um testing the legitimacy of the system
because the system has got to be able to
endure the fool
and that shows that it's being run
correctly and if the full
it's like when the king kills the fool
you know you are dealing with the
tyrannical kings the fool is meant to be
able to say anything
and everyone should be able to laugh at
him and then everyone's in their right
place that's where the fool wanted to be
it's where the king wants the fool to be
it was theoretically and that there is
like an understanding and an
implicit understanding that this is the
order and i think again this is just an
expression of natural human
consciousness and different personality
types working together
um because honestly i was always the
class clown when i was in school you
know i was i'm happy to play people i
like
you know i i have i have great great
mirth in provoking
serious reactions from people who should
know better than to react to what i'm
doing
you know and so ancient like medieval
culture they every year they had uh
they had different fool festivals they
had a festival called the feast of fools
they had a feast of the ass
where they would bring a donkey into the
church and like bring it up the altar
and people would pray like donkeys and
stuff like
so part of medieval culture was always
to integrate this
aspect of reality that's why medieval
churches are built the way they do and
why
on the outside of churches there are
gargoyles and monsters and
why in the margin of medieval
manuscripts they have marginalia where
they have all this crazy stuff going on
and like
weird upside down you know mix of
animals and humans just like
the cosmic vision of the world how on
the edge of the world are all these
monsters well on the edge of the
manuscript they're monsters and on the
edge of the church they're monsters
and so my my basic argument about people
understanding
religious patterns is that they're
fractal in nature right they
they have a pattern of being and then
they manifest those
patterns at all levels of reality so
the cosmic the the social and then the
personal because on your fringe you also
have
weird like undealt with stuff that is
not totally in line with what you would
want or what you would want your line to
be
so even the human person is made like a
church and the church is made like the
cosmos
and that's basically the mythic
structure of the let's say the christian
mythological structure
uh which as you said as we're getting
rid of it then
you know the world becomes topsy-turvy
and upside down
yeah and i i really think that is the
case um
and then and this this is the thing i
think um didn't richard dawkins actually
say
something to this effect as well
recently that there
there may have been something about
christianity that was actually worth
preserving
um but thank you richard thank you even
for taking this yeah yeah but but the
but the thing
that the the i mean it's all well and
good it's very easy to deconstruct
someone else's uh
positive vision of the world um but if
you're not gonna replace it with any
with something then it's going to be
replaced by anything and it seems to be
this sort of like drive towards absolute
uh freedom or autonomy that is
where we're heading and i don't think
that's going to be a very healthy thing
for people generally
yeah and so though then the question is
what do we do yeah um and and my
call like the people and this is hard
this is let's say it's hard a lot for a
lot of people to get there is that
it has to be real like it you have to
get involved you have to get engaged
and so we have a lot of people that are
theoretically there
but there are not a lot of people that
are willing to to dive back in
like to go to actually go to church like
not a lot of people are willing to go to
church
well i know i've got to be honest i'm
one of these people
i'm not going to go to a church and
well actually that's not true i go to
lots of churches just as a tourist
um i i don't do it for religious reasons
um
and so okay yeah so let's what what what
are the options then to
the the ex-new atheist who is
finding themselves a bit uh adrift in a
sea of chaos
uh they don't have any particular
purpose in their life
but they can't find themselves believing
in a religion
where can they go i don't know if
there's a solution
in the sense that my my solution has
rather been to reinvigorate christianity
and to give it its original because one
of the things that has to break in our
mind is to think that all these people
before us were idiots like once you
break that then
when you read the church fathers when
you read it augustine or you read
uh you know i i have my own favorite
church fathers
you realize they knew exactly what they
were talking about and they did it very
deliberately
and so it also helps you to kind of
reinvigorate
christianity in a manner in which then
the intellectually honest person
is actually able to engage and that's
let's say the people around me
i would say that that's what's happening
with them is that they
they actually understand what this is
about like when they go they go to
church
they see that the space of the church is
organized
in a cosmic pattern they realize that
the year of
the liturgical year let's say follows a
pattern of storytelling in a cosmic
pattern
and they realize that the story of of
christ and death and resurrection
that's the story of everything like it's
it's actually the pattern of reality
which is showing itself to you
and once you once you kind of are able
to re
to get back the the depth of the message
then then you're able to engage and then
i
there are thousands of people that have
been following me that are just they're
they're going back to church usually a
traditional church not like a
kind of pop you know uh protestant type
church but rather really the liturgical
churches because
liturgy is really a cosmic has a cosmic
pattern the way that the
the actual ritual of the church is set
up and the way you have this hierarchy
of space and this hierarchy and time
and everything kind of flows out into
into the world
it's a completely once you get it then
it's not it doesn't bother you so much
like you're participating in the giant
dance
and you you you get involved so that's
what i've been seeing i've actually
i've been seeing a lot of people who are
who are going back one of the
alternatives is people who make up these
new religions a lot of people
are there a lot of new pagans and stuff
people who want to make up because they
they don't like christianity they want
to
to recapture some some idea of like
pagan gods or whatever
i've seen that stuff uh people have a
union want to have like a more
psychological approach
which i understand i have sympathy for
that too because it's true
the problem about that is that you have
to realize that it stacks up
if this is really the pattern of reality
and then you you go into like a
psychological version of the religious
pattern yeah it's like it's gonna work
because it's true yeah but how does it
stack up in terms of the other
higher beings like how does it stack up
in terms of your community your family
you know your nation and it's a europe
in general like how does it
it has to stack up in reality yeah what
what is the predictive power of it you
know will it be able to tell you
you know will it be able to predict your
wife's reaction to a thing or your
children's reaction to a thing or
you know your neighbors your friends you
know will you be a better person by the
end of it all of these sort of
considerations
that have just gone by the wayside like
the very it's
i find it strange that the word virtue
is so unfashionable
because everyone demonstrates virtues
all the time
everyone respects virtues when they see
them and they revile
vices and say by the same capacity and
you can't help yourself but to do it
and yet we're still not allowed to talk
about virtue
you know the question is never ask you
know is it good or bad well
you know but is it virtuous is it you
know should you be doing it because it
implies that there is a set of
uh sort of overarching prescriptions
that maybe
you should be following even if you know
in the immediate there's no particular
harm from having that extra cookie and
that extra cookie after five years of
eating extra cookies you know the harm
you know you know
and and so that there is that is
definitely advice and you know you
shouldn't be doing it and
we've we've kind of moved away from the
i guess autocratic
deity telling you that's the case
through the priest
uh now it seems that people have been
left in a position where they've kind of
got to figure this out on their own
and that scene hamstrings one of the
things too that is harder for i think in
terms of
the religious question a lot of people
what's hard and i can probably see it in
in your
vision is that one of the things that
religion does is that it appeals to
every level
of reality that it appeals to every type
of person as well
and so because it is a vector of unity
it's the way in which we bind ourselves
together
then it has to appeal to the illiterate
uh
dumbest person in society and so
one of the things that people struggle
to do is that if they
they encounter that the place where it
deals with the let's say the most
illiterate person and they get turned
off by that
rather than understand that these this
aspect is actually necessary
and then there are higher levels that
you can attain without necessarily
having to care or to be involved in the
more
let's say superstitious or lower parts
like you know if
you go to church and it's annoying
because you'll meet someone who's a
super
zealot and is a super yeah like is it is
fundamentalist or is kind of has weird
superstitious ideas but it's like
those people are part of the world
you're not gonna get rid of them so how
do you deal with it you have to deal
with it
and if you disengage and you say well
it's for them but it's not for me
then who is going to be the elite of
this thing that is going to help
those people understand and live with it
in the way that they can
because there has to be an elite that's
been an intellectual elite that is
that is giving the information or else
it gets weird when it comes to the
bottom
i i always thought that this was really
where the new atheists dropped the ball
the most
and i didn't realize that at the time
but what the
the new atheists kind of were expressing
was a kind of cognitive privilege
it was you know it's very easy for them
to say well i'm you know 150 iq sam
harris and i've worked out that all of
religion is nonsense and
let me explain to you my my meditative
secular meditations or whatever it
does but you know my my cousin isn't
150 iq and he's been in and out of jail
he needs moral guidance in his life
uh he's not religious but they you know
i mean it doesn't have to be religion i
i i i got him to read plato and
aristotle and he he was like i only read
half of it it changed my life
you know and it's like yes it will you
know it doesn't like this this is the
thing i think there's got to be a
secular replacement for it
because i think that um unless uh unless
you're inculcated into religion as a
child with a genuine sort of spiritual
belief in god
unless you're lucky enough to develop
that i think it's i mean i don't ever
see myself having that right
so i don't have you don't see yourself
what you don't see yourself believing
god
no no not having not having like genuine
religious beliefs or anything like that
i just
i i whatever whatever is in a person
that they're feeling with that i just
don't have that um i i i
i understand like the desire for it i i
understand that
you know the the i i mean i went to
i went to a mass in a catholic church in
italy when i was visiting
um pompeii
visiting the pompeii and in the in the
city they've got this lovely church
and me and my wife went in just to you
know see what it was like
and the sense of community was very very
evident you know there was something
more going on here than merely
singing christian hymns or catholic
hymns um
you know there were there was there was
something binding about
it and you can see the appeal of the
thing i just i really do think though
we're kind of um at least in britain at
the very least we're kind of
post-christian
at this point and i i think you're gonna
find yourself very very
uh hard-pressed to get people back into
the churches but i think that
you could present a worldview that is
secular that still has
a kind of meaning i mean i personally
have been promoting aristotle a lot just
because
he doesn't ever appeal to deities and
it's quite a holistic view of a human
that he has you know
he's got he seems to have got all the
pieces you know fairly in line actually
first time frankly and i mean i've been
i've been approaching the world with an
aristotelian view
to you know try and be virtuous and i've
lost loads of weight i'm
a lot more healthy and fit than i am now
my kids are happy and i'm happy and
you know i i just feel better for at
least being trying to do something and
moreover i'm not i don't i mean i
personally have never felt that i've not
had any sense of meaning
but my my view of what the good life is
has changed because i in my 20s and like
mid-30s i was like you know the consumer
you know i would just play video games i
would eat
junk food i'd drink bottles of coke blah
blah blah and now i look back and think
wow
i'm annoyed that i was allowed to do
that i am annoyed
that i essentially wasted 10 15 years of
my life just existing
you know not building anything not
improving myself not learning anything
well i didn't
but like you know not anything that i
think maybe i should have learned
in retrospect and and well no
like you know i i was into history so
i'm quite lucky i you know i'd actually
learned something of some revel
relevance um but uh but there are lots
of people who aren't learning anything
of any relevance and they're just sat in
the sort of kuma mindset
and now i'm not in that now i'm in the
sort of like let's write no you know a
man's job is to build things
so how so in your let's say in your idea
and i
and i think you're right i think that at
least for your experience i i'm sure
that it's true
the question is what's the binding agent
yes
how does it stack up like so aristotle
offers
a way of being what christianity offered
was taking
aristotle and plato and plutinus and the
let's say hellenistic thinkers and
putting that in a story
and a sacred space and a sacred timeline
which would which would bind people
together in
in terms of identity like i said in
terms of space and then in terms of
of how they participate in in time it
would qualify time you would say
and and i don't see how you're like
what what what would bind your community
absolutely
right yeah you're right you're
absolutely right i i can only
be speaking from my own personal
perspective because that's aristotle's
perspective that's where he's he's
that's where he's originating from and
that's probably why so many of the
the church fathers the thought leaders
of the the catholic church
just called him the philosopher you know
he's he's the guy you start with
i mean you know he's it's a great start
but as you say i'm i'm never going to
end up
with that catholic church experience in
italy where you've got a community that
is genuinely
bound by some kind of glue um at the
moment i've
i've actually been doing a lot of
research in sort of like
english folklore and the sort of the
moral lessons from that
because i i'm an englishman you know it
seems that a sort of national identity
might be something
that could be a binding agent there you
know a bit of patriotism or something
like that but
um but you're i mean you are right it
would be easier if this was religion
um but i i think one of the things we
saw that
the nationalism we saw it happened that
was the 20th century
yeah that's i don't i don't want to call
it nationalism because
i i agree with george orwell's
definition on nationalism and that's a
that's a power game that's what you're
aiming for there but a patriotism
i think again by all will's definition
it's a love of the place
rather than a desire for power and i
think that's a that's a that's a more
wholesome way of approaching it
um and i i think that love of the place
can also be a binding agent
so i'm hoping that i can discover
something in there that might be useful
but it's all still you know i haven't
smoothed it out yet
not i'm not writing a manifesto yet or
anything you know
just just trying to trying to live a
better life to show people look it is
possible it's not even very hard
it's just about your decision-making you
know you just have to make the right
decisions
i mean i'm interested in exploring
though like i'm interested in exploring
like at this point let's say you know
you were you were like a kind of new
atheist type you know
several years ago and though at this
point the notion
that consciousness is part of reality
like let's say
that way right that the the human the
conscious perspective is part of how
reality unfolds and you can't avoid it
like it just
categories are part of or else it's like
a quantum field of possibility but
you need intelligence or pattern to kind
of to
to bring things together in terms of
actual phenomena and so once you kind of
see that you see that
let's we can call it intelligence right
so intelligence is the manner in which
the world reveals itself to a certain
extent it
participates in reality and so the the
traditional
view is that those intelligences
they don't stop at you and me
intelligence is actually a part of
reality it's a pattern of reality
so those intelligences stack up and so
you'll say something like there's an
angel of london
right and so london because it has an
identity like how can you define a city
like
it's not like an apple it's really hard
to say what like
it's it's a it's a million billion
phenomena and then but nonetheless we
perceive unity in it
and that unity is real it's not just
subjective it's a real unity
and so there's an angel of london and
that intelligence
is the principality which manifests
the unity of the city and then that that
that intelligence scales up and it and
it continues to scale
until you reach an infinite intelligence
and that infinite intelligence is the
the
the pattern of all patterns so i i think
that um
again i'm gonna have to be one of those
annoying secularists about this go for
it
i have to i i think that um the way
the best way i would describe that is uh
i think you're talking to sort of the
the essence or the character of the
thing um but i agree with you that there
is
something that you could describe as you
know the angel of london and
like the spirit of it the spirit of the
thing you know there
there absolutely is and this is i think
a part of
human cognition the way we again the
sort of mythological thinking we don't
know all the details
but we know that when you know when you
go to x
country you're going to have a kind of
experience there that you're not going
to get in y country
you know you know these things true so
the you know the sort of character or
the
essence of the spirit whatever we would
call it spirit's not
a secular word but anyway you know what
i mean um
i i agree but like how are you going to
protect
your narrative from the
deconstructionists because
i i i'm actually fully on board with
this kind of mythological heuristic
but the deconstructionist will come
along and say well now you've got to
prove it
so what do you say to that so you have
to ride the deconstruction thing
until the end you have to just write it
all the way to the end
right and you have to write it until you
realize look
the argument goes something like this
the argument goes something like
i talk about the reality the essence of
of
the cup right and then they say yeah but
there's no essence of the cup like what
are you talking about right it's just a
bunch of stuff show me the essence
that you can't find the essence it's
just a bunch of stuff right and so then
you ride that until the end you say yeah
you're right
and so uh and then they'll say the cup
is just a human category
and you'll say all right yeah and and so
what is it if it's not
if it's not a human category then it's
just a bunch of
stuff and atoms material yeah and so it
doesn't matter
it doesn't matter and so now i don't
even have a drink you don't care
and so the idea is the things we care
about
the cup that's part of how it manifests
its essence
we are let's say so say maximus the
confessor who is one of my favorite
church fathers he talks about how
the human being is a laboratory for the
essences of the world
and so the essences of reality the human
person
acts as the gardener so adam in the
garden of eden is a gardener
and and the human categories the
categories of the world
go through the consciousness of human
beings
and manifest their reality through our
consciousness
but the thing is that that's not that's
not an illusion
or it's as real as anything is real
there's nothing else
that you have access to you only have
access to that reality there is no other
reality you have access to you can posit
it
imaginary reality where those categories
don't exist but
you you don't have access to it and so
that's real and once that's real
then the higher categories are as real
as that one
and then and then it continues to scale
up there's no there's no way to
to me it's like there's no way to avoid
that you've really got to get to the
the very bedrock where nothing exists
yeah and
but the and one one thing i noticed is
the deconstructionist will often make
exemptions for other civilizations or
other cultures other peoples they'll
they'll sit there and go well you have
nothing but they look at them you know
how does the shaman call the lightning
and things like this like well
that's a big question but you know by
the same standard that they would say
well they're allow you know if all
full value is subjective and let's just
say that it is for the sake of argument
all value is subjective all beliefs are
arbitrary or
the product of an imperfect process then
can i not just appeal to the very same
method of validating that culture for my
own and just say well this isn't
this isn't universal this is not you
know interchangeable this is actually
something unique and particular and
special and not shared by
you know the the tribe over there or
whatever it is and
if you're going to validate them then
you have to validate me on that standard
that's been the surprise of
post-modernism like the surprise of
post-modernism has been to open up a
space
for us to revalue our culture because in
saying
because that for a while it was like
these these these
european ideals they're universal
and so now we judge all these other
tribes and we see them as being
uh you know no good and they're they're
the barbarians whatever whatever
and then then we start to say no how can
we say that it's horrible
right like those other cultures are are
are just as good or good or they're okay
and they're fine
and then we start to real but we don't
realize that we're still
in that position where we're using
european culture as a universal view
then it starts to turn and say well what
are these universal values that you
think are supposedly there to judge
everybody else
bring that down and then now we now all
of a sudden european culture we can look
at it and say hey
that that has value like look at that
look at that thing look at look at this
this this whole culture that we had we
can see it now because they told us we
can't just stand in it
invisibly so we stand in it visibly and
we consciously
embrace our european tradition and the
christian history and
you know the the also the testimony of
the ancients into the greeks in terms of
rome in terms of our connection with
mesopotamia all of that we're like
all right then then if all of if it's
all these tribes and everything then i
can see because it's mine
so i can love it and i know if all value
is subjective then they have literally
no grounds to say you can't have it
either because you can say but it's just
my choice it's just my choice
and that's that's the ultimate defense
and they end up
they end up actually in doing that they
end up actually
putting your position in the supreme
powerful position
they end up actually inadvertently
elevating
the kind of rationalistic european point
of view
as being universal they do it inevitably
and so it's like i'm actually more
postmodern than you are
because i would just want to love my
culture and love my tradition and
participated and be involved in it
and and as i said from their point of
view they literally can't tell you
you're wrong
because it's just well it's my my
subjective judgment that's enough
but then the next step though is to
still see is to still be capable of
seeing
that the patterns are true
right the pattern is true even though
there's difference let's say between
different cultures
the pattern let's say of center and
periphery the pattern of hierarchy of
up and down this is a universal thing
like it's everywhere
and and in our culture we have a
particular manifestation of that
and i would argue that in in the story
of christianity i think we have
a very very particular and i would say
um
powerful vision of what that means
ultimately because what we offer at the
top of the hierarchy
is self-sacrifice which is not there i
don't they don't find that very much you
find a little hint of it in other
cultures
you have sacrificed others but the idea
that because sacrifice is a necessary
part of reality
then the key that christianity offers is
the the key is self-sacrifice
so once the top the people at the top
are there
to love those at the bottom and those at
the bottom submit to those at the top
because those at the top are there to
care for them like that's the pattern
that christianity offers
which which obviously doesn't derails
all the time like
it's an ideal pattern it goes off the
rails all the time but it's something
that we need to understand
without that even the social justice
woke
culture can't hold because it's actually
based in a weird perversion of that idea
you know it's it's not a full one it's a
kind of inverted weird perverted one but
it needs christianity for it to hold i
think um i think you're right about
um the the sort of the self-satisfied
the robin hood tales are in fact a great
example of this
um you know the robin hood being a
product of the failing of the system and
the fact that
the the top is not considerate of the
bottom and understanding of their
the proper place that they have um that
is a very
very um bold way of uh
showing i think no no i really think it
is i i think it's excellent you know the
yeah
and the the fact that it all writes
itself when the
when the proper king returns that's i
think it's a fantastic story
um and i think there's a fantastic moral
in that though that's the thing you know
this yeah
and so one of those one of my main
points has been that the modern world
let's say from the enlightenment has
been a kind of weird d
incarnation where in christianity
demystifying things we offer like in
christianity we offer this idea
that this this vision of the hierarchy
which is that you have
you do a posit something above in the
hierarchy which is which is has to be
respected
and and let's say submitted to but it's
there to love and to care for that which
is below
that which is below also has its
function because without it it's the
body of the head let's say right
the body of christ uh and so what the
modern world seems to be is like a weird
deincarnation
where the body now wants to revolu have
a revolution against the the head
and the top the hierarch hierarchical
part wants to separate from the body
and to just be this elite that doesn't
actually care or that
that just presses down and pushes down
on those that are below
and and so people take one side or the
other and they fight
the other side people who want absolute
order let's say the nazis are the
the greatest example want to cut off the
margin get rid of everything exceptional
anything that doesn't fit in the
categories we need to cut it off burn it
and the others are saying no the
exceptions are the rule like
all this all the people at the bottom
need to take rise up and take
you know the what the king has
illegitimately so it's a weird
deformation of of the christian story
it's a weird it's like an antichrist
i guess that's how the christian way of
talking about it where it's like these
two extremes
are happening and they're supposed to be
together
like that's how they're supposed to go
but i like i i agree with you completely
when you say um
this has real world effects this
manifests in the real world
and i i mean it's everywhere like
uh the the sort of uh the traditional
uh christian protestant culture of the
english-speaking world
has produced the most enviable cultures
in the world the
political cultures as in ev everyone
wants to live in an english-speaking
country
everyone is desperate to get into an
english-speaking country because of the
rule of law property rights
and limited government these are these
are like the one thing that england
really got right
is good governance and this has taken a
long time and it's because of in my
opinion
geographic uh convenience uh the fact
that we were
you know an island and there weren't any
major threats on this island so we had
the space to be able to
suddenly you know order the world and
you know get an understanding with the
people at the top but look
we're not just here for your pleasure we
are actually people on our own rights
and then this you know you get this
great agreement
and uh and when you remove all of this
the the understanding that there is a
hierarchy to the world there will
inevitably be a hierarchy to the world
not just that there should be
a hierarchy to the world when you get
rid of all that look at what we have now
you know we've got
people who have you know delinquents who
are depressed
our intellectuals hate our own countries
they hate the countries they were born
and bred in
the kids in some communities
ridiculous amounts of crime and and
suffering that
is caused by the breakdown of these
traditional hierarchical structures
and so we can actually point to the
effect of getting rid of this sort of
pattern of life and say this is good
you're not going to choose that for
yourself
who is going to choose to be some you
know a you know an inner city kid
who's now in a gang and has to carry a
knife around like it happens in london
all the time
because of the breakdown of the family
there's no father figures et cetera et
cetera
who's choosing that you know no one
wants that that's awful it's a trap
and it's actually we're actually in a
good place you know this idea that
you know you need to reach rock bottom
before you can look up because
100 years ago or 150 years ago the
project
like the this kind of enlightenment
project was still
like in the 19th century this kind of
rationalistic project was like
because they didn't they didn't have the
there were it was in the future still
they were saying
we're going to do this it's going to be
great we're going to have beautiful star
trek type societies where everybody is
just
scientifically super advanced and also
everybody cares for each other and also
loves each other
and now we've come to the fruits of that
way of thinking and now we can point to
them and say okay so this is what you
said a hundred years ago are
do you still think you can hold this
discourse now that we see the
consequence
you know and you can no now we're i
would say that
people exactly and so we if you want to
advocate for a mythological point of
view as being legitimate
now's the time because it's like look at
us like i don't know
my third neighbor i don't know them what
happened i don't live in this even live
in the city
you know i live in a suburb but i don't
know my third neighbor like how is that
possible
it's crazy isn't it it's crazy the and
the the sort of at the the atomization
of people i don't think
i i think that it's been vastly
understated just how social
cr human beings are and how necessary
and but this is why i've
i've gone straight back to aristotle
because he deliberately said
you know includes no you need a social
life you are a man of the polis
you're political you are familial you
have to incorporate all of this so
you know in a world where there's no
obvious direction that seems to be a
good start i've found
and especially as an atheist who just
can't go to religion i'm sorry
i think there's a part of me that would
the
wishes i was religious you know because
yeah i've seen
the comfort that religious people have
taken from their faith
you know and i can see that it helps and
it makes them
feel better about bad things that happen
in the world
but i i just know that it's not for me
yeah well i think
maybe one of the things also that is
that you might also have some idols like
you might have
your perception of what god is like you
think god is this and so you're like i
can't believe in this like i can't
believe in some guy
in the sky who tells me what to do it's
like like
that's that's your okay so your aunt
maybe believed that who who
dropped out of school and but you know
thomas aquinas never believed that
and the church fathers never believed
that and sanger nissan said i'm actually
the confessor
they talked about the infinite and they
used ontological categories to talk
about
god to talk about this idea of that
which is beyond being
and manifest itself in being and they
these are the categories that the
high theologians use and so sometimes we
also
we all like i said we have to always
remember that there's an imagistic
aspect of the story which is necessary
and is important
uh and has to reach all the way down to
the most uneducated person but
but that's that's something that maybe
that that's a work that can be done in
in each of us to break that down to
break down those idols that
that we've accepted like we've been told
that this is what god is but that's
that's not what the hot that's not what
the great theologian thought god was
so i i totally agree with you that
now is the time to start pushing uh a
mythological understanding of what a
person is
you know not not just the world but what
a human being is and a human being is a
collection of stories
um and but the the the most difficult
bit is going to i think be getting
past the marxists the materialists who
say
uh well you're just a science denier
you're you're
making up things that have no bearing on
reality and things like that how how are
we going to address that
well one of the things that i've been
doing is trying to get down to the
basics like really basics
and so i i've made a video for example
called the inevitability of ritual
and i'm trying i tried to show people
that
if you look at the catholic mass or you
look at i'm an orthodox myself you look
at it at an orthodox ma
an orthodox liturgy and you think it's
stupid because it's all a lot of these
people
processing and bowing in front of each
other and you know
lifting up books and it's like what is
going on right what is this like
kind of nonsense thing that's going on
but what i like to try to point to
people is that we engage in those types
of acts
all the time every day right a handshake
is no less
a ritual act than uh than a procession
and there are rules to how we engage
with human beings we
we face them you don't talk to the back
of the head of someone you know and i
tell people if you want to know that you
are constantly engaged in ritual
then try to do the opposite just once
and see what happens like try to pick
your nose in front of the person you're
talking to
try to uh to not let them speak at all
let's say because there's a normal
rhythm of speaking where
it's like there's a pressure when you're
speaking at some point there's a normal
pressure to kind of stop and let the
other person speak and those rhythms are
there are liturgical rhythms they're
ritual rhythms
between between people and like i said
handshakes saying hello
it's non-stop we're our whole world is
is
even even like not you know not letting
the toilet seat up like
we have all these ritual behaviors that
are just part of our everyday life and
so
i've been tending to just point to the
lowest ones the ones that people can't
avoid
and say so so if you say like shaking
hands
you think that's real do you think that
that's just a convention
because if it's just a convention are
you going to get rid of it and then what
are you going to replace it with
because you need a way to greet someone
and shaking hands is actually a really
good way to greet somebody
it has all the it has all the symbolism
in it you're reaching out with your hand
you're showing you don't have anything
to hurt the other person
you're having a physical contact with
that person and it's not too close
not too far it's like a nice distance
where you you're not like
going up to strangers and hugging them
or something strange like that
and so it it actually is manifesting
ritually
what you're doing which is an encounter
with a person and
then it that scales up every single
thing
in a liturgy or in a mass is like that
it's just that
you don't have the capacity of of seeing
it but it's it all of those things are
completely logical and they're
completely
reasonable in the notion that in order
for society to exist you need patterns
and and those scale up to something like
a sacred space right and so
people who don't understand the church
for example i tell them your house is
made like a church
your your house has to be made like a
church you have a porch on the outside
which is the narthex of the church which
is a in between space
and then you have like a place where you
gather your living room
then you have a more intimate space
around your table and then you have your
bedroom where you don't invite strangers
into your bedroom
and you you it's only you and your
spouse to go and go into your bedroom
and that's the same structure as a
church you have the altar where it's
just the priest
you have the place where it's all the
people greeting and then you have the
north x where
it's more open and less is and
yeah absolutely and i think i think um
i've been i've been reading a philosophy
called john mackie australian liberal
philosopher
and i really like his conception of
institutions
uh institutions uh which is essentially
what you're describing as rituals they
institutions have a an often informal
settle
set of rules that everyone understands
like the game of chess
is an institution well i don't even have
to be able to speak another language
like you know i could sit down with a
russian guy and bring out a chessboard
and i know that he's going to move a
pawn first and if he doesn't
i'll you know i'll be able to point to
that and he'll know why i've
i've taken exception to him moving you
know the queen or something you know
without moving a pawn whatever it is
you know there there's a there's a
there's a there's a set of rules that
may be formal maybe informal
but everyone understands and agrees to
and that's how we can join together in
activities by these shared rules so like
you say you know
the the liturgical mass might might look
silly where they've got the incense
sensors and all this sort of stuff
but it's only silly if you don't accept
that people are bound together
by these rituals it's only silly like
that and
again the the thing that drives me crazy
is that the very same people say well
that's silly we'll see like
i know zulu warriors jumping up and down
in the air and say oh isn't this a
beautiful expression of a native culture
well so is this whatever we've been
doing for the past
thousand years is also our native
culture that binds us all together
you know come on give us a break and
moreover what do you want to replace it
with you know this sort of like oh well
we're universalist now
there's no such thing as like western
culture now now we're all universal it's
like okay but
i don't want to be you know i actually
want to be a particular thing that i can
take pride in that
i can work towards if i do the rituals
then i build the thing because a thing
is defined by what it is
as much as what it's not and so you know
if i can't put those building blocks
down
then i can't build on top of them and we
never have the
the great church i suppose you could
describe it as that we're building in
each in our own lives
if you don't have any identity at all
and you just have a weird universal mush
then you become potential for another
identity and it's really like
it's a this is the the idea it's almost
in evolutionary terms it's like if
you're
too generalist in terms of your
evolutionary practice then then
a specialist is going to come in like a
knife and is going to slice your thing
up and you're going to take it from you
and that's just how it just that's just
a pattern of reality
it's not a it's not a it's not something
i want or not want it's just that's just
how it works
well any anyone with a strong normative
view of the world that can just
reject you know our universalist
enlightenment view
that we've been reduced to uh will look
appealing as well
they'll look strong i can build
something i can bring people together
you know you will salam five times a day
to allah or whatever it is
you know what whatever whatever alien
identity is arrived it'll it'll be
attractive because
what what's the alternative we're
offering you sludge we're offering you
no progress we're offering you nothing
you know anyone else will come in boldly
and
view this as right for the taking and
the thing about you you mentioned
marxist materials before
marxist materialists are actually
extremely religious
yes their their storytelling is very
religious
the only difference is that it's upside
down i was talking about this recent i
did a video on monsters
where i was showing how karl marx talks
about these
like kind of uh earth monsters right the
pucks and the the robin goodfellows and
all these kind of earth monsters
and he sees them as like agents in his
revolution
he's like he he understands that the the
ghouls and the demons and the and these
like
these these kind of monsters of the edge
they're actually images of what he wants
to accomplish and
bringing those and having those take
over the world karl marx was
was a very very uh mythological writer
it's just that it was a satanic like a
satanic
vision it was an upside-down vision and
it was totally false i mean
just the very nature of all of human
history being the story of class
conflict
that's that's a mythos right there and
it's not a true one either which is
really interesting it's not
like that you know um and then you get
the sort of like almost well
not even almost the religious veneration
of lenin
and the the way that um lenin developed
the sort of first
um sort of marxist cult of personality
that lenin could do no wrong he became
and he i mean london himself hated this
cult of personality this was not
i've just finished a biography on him
actually which is good timing actually
but you know he he hated this cult of
personality but he couldn't escape
it because it's everywhere it's just
part of human nature and
one of the one of the things that i've
noticed again i've been reading a lot
about 20th century dictators in the last
month or two
and every single one of them you get the
same pattern in
in lenin or stalin or mao and then you
you can match this same pattern back
through the centuries you know
you go you know right back to like the
persian empire where there's
this common view where okay we're all
suffering now
but if only stalin knew if only mao knew
if only lenin
if only the the the king of kings knew
he would come and help us with our
suffering you know this this assumption
that the guy at the top
is looking out for you is a very natural
thing for the people at the bottom
and it's really sad in the case of the
20th century communist dictators
because they did not care about you at
all yeah they they had no
thought to you at all yeah and it was
really a failure of hierarchy
because hierarchy is layered it the idea
that
because we have this idea that's we're
talking about how negative people view
hierarchy
we have this idea that hierarchy is like
this horrible dictator at the top and
then everybody at the bottom that's
a modern vision the idea of a leader
above and everybody else below that's a
total modern vision
a normal hierarchy has levels of of
of management at all these different
levels
and so let's say in a normal world if
even if there's a king the king can't do
without his aristocracy
and his aristocracy can't do without
their like knights that they've that
they that are vassals to them
and those knights can't do without the
peasants that are that are subject to
them
and so the king has to be careful he's
always playing a line where
if he alienates his aristocracy too much
they'll kill him
they'll just kill him or they'll or
they'll or they'll they'll start to
fight
you know with with him or they'll fight
amongst themselves or whatever
so hierarchy actually is always both
separation and the means of unity and
that's what people struggle
so sometimes it can be it can become
more means of separation
but then there usually tends to be if
you do that too much it's normally going
to
come back where it's going to then start
to act as a as a unifying principle
because or else it's going to shatter
i i really like um i it's also like a
method of definition as well
um you know it defines things into
existence
that give people meaning and inclusion
but i i i find it the
the way that you put that the
aristocrats will kill them that's
exactly true i mean that's what happened
in the english civil war
and people now find it strange that we
would want
uh that we that you know the the english
of the time would bring in
charles's son charles ii to be king
again you know that that seems strange
well you've just had a revolution
you've just got rid of the king why are
you installing a new king it's like well
there should be a king that's why
you know that's what they thought you
know in the 17th century you know the
the idea that you could you know go
without the king that's that's very
alien idea that's a very modern idea you
know that just wouldn't apply back then
um and also the king like the king acted
as a trans
national uh person like that's
also the emperor like the idea of the
byzantine emperor for example he acted
as it as a transnational figure because
it's difficult to have different nations
or different tribes of different groups
uh be together and it's difficult when
it's just like one tribe that say that
is that that
has always has leaders but in the notion
of the byzantine emperor for example the
byzantine emperor was
was sometimes armenian sometimes greek
would have you know different people
could access it was messy and violent
and and obviously there was a lot of
backstabbing happening but
once the emperor was there then he acted
like i said as someone who was beyond
the different
national identities and everybody could
kind of identify with and i feel like
that
let's say the the royalty in england in
the uk has played that role to a certain
extent
where it's like okay you know the scots
and the irish like we all would disagree
but
yeah we still like the the monarchy
because the monarchy is is actually none
of us
it's actually a mix of all of us it's
like a joining of all these
different identities because they all
have these these bloodlines that are
that have kind of joined together and so
they're not one or the other they're
like these something above above
the national identities and so we can we
can pledge allegiance to them still
kind of not like each other but it's
still acting as a binding agent for all
of us at the same time
yeah it gives it gives us a sort of
unifying moral groundwork to
to stay on you know um but right
uh jonathan this has been an amazing
conversation i've really enjoyed it
um yeah i'd really like uh to do this
again sometime if that's all right well
yeah any time no fantastic because i'm
i'm still like developing this sort of
like
secular view of the um the mythological
because i like you say i it's a part of
reality it's a part of the human
condition there's no questioning
it's got to be established the
enlightened and this is the thing i
think the enlightenment was wrong about
humans are not they can't purely be
rational they can't pretend like they
have a
you know universal understanding of the
world and everything around them it's
it's
you know we've we've got to accept our
limitations as people but um
but anyway thank you again so much for
joining me really appreciate it so if
you if you want like you can check i did
quite a few videos on my channel they
talk about this particularly i did a
video called secular
uh sacred art and secular terms you know
and
talking about trying to help secular
people understand it so if you have time
check it out and thanks thank you
where can people find your channel is it
just under your name i just jonathan
pedro on youtube you'll find my channel
great thank you very much all right